why did I choose while Luigi and Luigi
because everyone chooses Mario everyone
chooses more item so it's like you got
to switch it up so I'm with Luigi and
then of course like his is a
it's Luigi's archenemies Waluigi
so today we were on our way to set which
is also known as the park down the
street from my house um we're gonna do a
little fight scene today with the MC
monkeys we got sin and malai following
us right now
I chose AMC monkeys because they are the
greatest screen fighting team on YouTube
if not outside of YouTube they're so
good
I can't not use them they're too good to
not be used DMC is in the process of
graphing a little fight scene I'm just
waiting I met their way right now yeah
basically I just give them a couple
points like I want I'll star star power
maybe use a stick he needs like the
hammer music from smash bros maybe do
something like the mustaches the pig
mustaches but honestly like they have
everything else like they're the best at
choreographing stuff so I just I'm just
using a stock runs today the t2i body
and I have an nd fader on here which
allows me to get like depth of field and
you know sunny areas years old I know
this was you got the hottest sweatiest
thermo it's a tickle fight the only good
thing about
overalls is a visitor like preparing for
battle they're strapping into to the
overall and you need help yeah I mean if
you need help getting dressed never like
you're gonna walk anyone your
transformation is complete I'm shooting
wider because when you're shooting a
fight scene like you want to see
everything you want to get in close with
the fighters and everything seems like
like fluid you know like the camera is
not shaky for example so that's why
that's one of the reasons why I use an
18-mile was the bad guy I don't know
that's a good question
then why is my how is the bad guy I'm
gonna I've ever played a good guy
well I well I has a really good like
like face and like aura about him in the
place like the gangsters and bad days
this practice of this upgrading he was
younger and he was a real thing when I
grew up in Long Beach that make sense
that plug it you could me here this is a
actually a motorcycle protective gear so
when you crash so what I'm wearing it
for is I'm gonna get thrown into the
tree hitting my back against it
and the tree is too much uneven you
don't know where you're gonna hit you
wanna try and guards what you can well
because this is a full-size it's bulky
so sometimes when you're wearing it
hundred like a t-shirt it shows a lot so
they actually so just the back sit by
itself and it's you can feel it a lot
more they run about maybe 40 50 dollars
to the L 7200 I'm using it for the last
shot but it's just a way better lens
than this when I here
this is like a this was the stock lens
that came at this camera it's probably
like a hundred fifty bucks this one is
more expensive than hundred bucks we're
always playing goofy characters you know
out-of-the-box characters and
many I'll make him love one
watch me move watch me fighting I'll
start loving wrong he actually had no
idea like what we could do with waluigi
when we got called for the for this
video to do a fight scene cam you know
we always we always study up on our
characters and add elements of the video
game or of the comic book you know just
out the characters and we're trying to
figure out what waluigi does and Holly
all he is is like long and Lincoln
didn't stand up straight
yeah so we just have to make up a bunch
of new story
every video is different in every style
of fight that's distant well depending
on what you want you want like a Hong
Kong Jackie Chan style feel like a
brawler like Japanese schoolyard fight
feel we'll take it one step at a time
and as far as the beats will go we'll go
as fast as our partners can go when
we've worked with each other for like
years and we know each other's rhythms
yeah
so we trust each other we go back we go
fast and we don't about him what's
unique about Clint is it is like
knowledge of martial arts and and like
Hong Kong movies it almost rivals ours
you know it's pretty crazy so when he
talks about something or he brings up an
idea we know exactly what he's talking
about and and vice versa and and in that
way we we have a really quickly
good work
I hope you guys enjoyed the video I hope
you guys enjoyed this behind the scenes
video and yeah I mean that's it my
Instagram is underscore corner if your
honor I don't care
[Music]